INFLATION  INFMING IT.
AND THERE'NOTHG TRE.
>> Brian: H WEAPONIZE THERS
WITHILLIONS OF DOLRS A HE
ALSOUT A MINIMUM CPORA TAX
AT 15% ANDHE MY STAGGERING
JOING US RIGHT NOWICHA
DAS HSEN.
IS NO NEW TES O THIS?
>> N HE IS WRO Y'RE RIGHT.
THERS N TAXES, THE NE
AND A HA PLACE.ETWN A ROCKRNME.
WE HAVE 9% AUAL ILATION
D WE HE TWO QUARTS O
NEGATI GROH ANY OF T PIC
YO POISON BRIAN.
WASERY UNPOPUL AND 81, AND
82.
VERY COURAGES.
THENTEREST RES TBREAK
IT SPENDG T GDOWN.
YOUAVEO DEREGUTE A
ENURAGE THE ECOMY, BUT WHE
YOUO THAT INTERE RAT GO UP
GROWTH.IX QUARRS ONEGATIVE
AND  WE BROUGHTACK A
STFLATION D AHOLE
GENETION HAS A WITSS F TWO
CARTER YEARS.198IN THE
THEY KEEPOINTG TOHIS.6
UNEMOYME RATE, NO DON'T USE
THE RECESSIOORD.
THAT ISLSO SLEADINGECAU
ITHERES A LAG BEHD
EMPLMENTND RESSION B THAI AN CSS
DOWN.
PEOPLE AREUYING LESS.
EMPLOYERS AULLING IN THEI
EXPANSIONARYLANSMERICAN SEE A DP
WEE GONNAEE AISE IN
UNPLOYMENT BUT ME
IMPORTANTL IT'S LOR
PAICIPT DISSIPION TE.
HAVE A LOT O PPLE WHO ARE
PARTICIPATINBECAE HE GOT A
CUURE RATE TO STA HOME.
THEY WE SSIDIZED BY THE
GOVEMENT WITH THESE MASSIVE
LASTEAR OF E TRP
MINIRATION ESPECIAY THE
JOBIDEN DEMONSTTION
THESE TRIIONSF DOLLAR THA
WOD SEAD AND GIVE ECKS TO
PEOP.
LOTF PEOPLE ARE AFRAID OF
COVID, THEOCKDN THAT A
I'M OUT OF HE.WE ARE PPLE WHO D'
PARTICIPATE CAUSTHEY DID NOT
WANT TGET VACCITEDITH
WITH THE MANDATES.KFORCE
WE HAVPEOP WHO HAV LG
VID MAYBE T MILONS OF TM
HAVE N BEE COVEREDI N'T E ANY OE
E AREA THEY WE VE
OPMIST.
EY SD WEREOT IA
RECEION BECAUSE WH 3UNPLOYNT.
I TNK IT'S IN A RE VY
PARTICIPATINGO IS ANOT
MISLDING FIGE T BEGIN WITH.
IT'S CAN EXPIN HER N HAVG
RY MH GROH.
I'M NOT SE H THEY DID IT
THEYANAG TO DO THIS F YOU
RECOVERING ECOMY WH NATAL
DEMANDS AT'SONNA ACCE
AFTER E LOCKDOWNS
E REGULATED, AAX IT,INFLATEDO DE
PICK YOUROISO RECESSION OR
STOP INFLATION.
Brian: WHILEETTI
FOALLY IN ENTER E COUNTRY
ABOUT.YHATE KNOW NOTHING
IHINK THE MOS EGREGIO ISTH INFT.
FLATION DUCTN ACT IS TO
THE CLIMAT CHA